[Musique]
hier matin je me suis levée du pied
gauche
en retard il n'étant plus habitué à
Paris je me retrouve dans un RER bondé
en plein air de pointe
incroyable je tombe sur un ancien
collègue à moi que j'ai pas vu depuis 4
ans rappelle le temps de lui dire
bonjour je dois descendre au prochain
arrêt
je passe devant une boulangerie j'ai
extrêmement envie d'un café je rentre
bonjour mademoiselle je suis désolée
nous n'avons plus de capuchon
je récupère mon café main gauche
ordinateur sous bras droit et j'envoie
le pas parce que je suis en retard mince
je bouscule en passant je me renverse du
café dessus
café sur le jean j'arrive en retard à
mon rendez-vous surexcité
et mon client me dit ça tombe bien
dans 15 minutes mon associé arrive tu
vas pouvoir la rencontrer
tu perds encore plus de stress
hier matin je me suis levée du pied
droit
je suis en retard mais je prendrai quand
même un café sur le chemin
magnifique cette vitrine incroyable une
des plus belles boulangeries que j'ai
jamais vues à Paris je vais prendre mon
café ici
je suis désolé mademoiselle mais nous
n'avons plus de capuchon
je récupère mon café en main gauche
ordinateur bras droit mais je suis en
retard donc j'envoie le pain
je bouscule quelqu'un je m'excuse
j'arrive à mon rendez-vous
et je suis très gênée de ces 15 minutes
de retard ce que j'explique à mon client
et il me dit c'est pas grave ça tombe
bien mon associé arrive dans 15 minutes
pendant ce temps prends le café que tu
n'as pas pu prendre me lance-t-il
oui
j'ai maintenant 15 minutes pour me
conditionner à mon rendez-vous
je décroche le contrat
comment se fait-il
qu'une seule et même journée puisse
avoir deux perceptions deux possibilités
de finalité
et j'ai envie de vous poser la question
dans la salle qu'est-ce qui a déjà
enchaîner une journée catastrophe femme
enlevée
voilà le proverbe la dash une
catastrophe sans catastrophe
et
depuis que je me suis posé cette
question je me suis intéressé de très
près au neurosciences
ça fait maintenant depuis plus de 2 ans
que je cherche que je lis que je
m'instruis sur le sujet et j'ai
découvert tout un tas de choses mais
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous en partager
seulement trois
qui à mon sens sont
réalisables au quotidien
pérenne et pour les plus rats gratuite
avant ça j'aimerais repartir sur les
bases
les bases on sait très bien que pour une
bonne construction il faut des bonnes
fondations et je pense que pour nous les
êtres humains bonne fondation ce serait
un sommeil de qualité une alimentation
variée équilibrée bouger son corps et
avoir un minimum d'interactions sociales
en effet
mais finalement est-ce qu'il existe une
formule magique qui ferait qu'on puisse
se lever tous les matins ou un maximum
de matins du pied droit
et pour ça je vais donc vous partager
les trois piliers fondamentaux qui à mon
sens peuvent changer votre journée votre
quotidien et peut-être je l'espère à
plus long terme votre vie en terme
général
la toute première chose la plus simple
que l'on puisse faire tout un chacun
c'est d'aller chercher la lumière
naturelle comme une plante
il s'avère que Andrew hiberman
professeur de neurosciences à Stanford à
révéler quelque chose d'excessivement
intéressant
prendre la lumière du soleil dans
l'heure qui suit votre réveil vous
permettrez d'augmenter un maximum
d'hormones bénéfiques pour continuer
votre journée incroyable n'est-ce pas et
avec les études qu'il a faites s'il
s'est rendu compte que globalement
toutes les personnes qui sortent dans
l'heure qui suit leur réveil pour aller
chercher les rayons du soleil ont une
amélioration nette de leur système
immunitaire une amélioration grande de
leur humeur ça aide aussi à se mettre en
mouvement pour le reste de la journée
et enfin dernière chose et non pas des
moindres
il s'avère que lorsque vous prenez la
lumière dans l'heure qui suit votre
réveil vous allez augmenter de façon
lente et contrôlée votre taux de
cortisol le cortisol est en hormone du
stress certes mais là vous le contrôlez
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que une
fois que vous avez eu ce pic de cortisol
16 heures plus tard vous allez sécréter
automatiquement de la mélatonine
c'est l'hormone pour aller faire dodo
l'hormone du sommeil et la boucle est
bouclée
j'ai envie d'aller un petit peu plus
loin parce que ça c'est facile on peut
le faire certes mais il y a d'autres
choses qu'on peut faire qui demande un
tout petit peu plus d'efforts
et ça ça va vous demander cinq minutes
dans votre journée
la gratitude
la gratitude ou
le besoin de reconnaissance en tout cas
le fait d'être reconnaissant
la gratitude
peut transformer les jours ordinaires en
action de grâce les tâches routinières
en joie et les opportunités ordinaires
en bénédiction
en fait c'est très simple on part du
principe que à partir du moment où vous
faites l'exercice de gratitude qui
consiste à dire que vous êtes bien que
vous appréciez les choses que vous avez
vous développez tout un tas d'hormones
une fois de plus excessivement bénéfique
et dans l'instant T
avec les études qui ont été réalisées le
simple fait de penser que vous appréciez
prendre une douche parce que vous avez
de la chance d'avoir de l'eau c'est un
exemple vous avez de la chance d'avoir
de l'eau et pour les plus chanceux de
l'eau chaude réduit drastiquement les
symptômes dépressifs améliore la qualité
de votre sommeil
et réduit la pression artérielle qui
infinie amène à une meilleure santé
cardiaque
vous avez deux possibilités pour exercer
ou pour faire un exercice de gratitude
la première c'est simplement y penser
comme je vous ai dit vous êtes sous la
douche et vous vous rendez compte de la
chance que vous avez de prendre cette
douche et la seconde et c'est celle que
je fais depuis deux ans maintenant
tous les jours
c'est ce petit carnet je me réveille
j'ouvre les yeux et je me dis à quel
point je suis chanceuse d'avoir tout un
tas de choses et je peux vous assurer
qu'au bout de deux ans je trouve encore
des nouvelles choses ça c'est parce que
la vie continue mais cet exercice a été
prouvé
qu'il permettait d'être bien plus
heureux
la dernière chose que j'aimerais vous
dire par rapport à la gratitude c'est
que vous allez révéler automatiquement
au moment où vous êtes en train de faire
cet exercice trois hormones très
intéressantes la première c'est la
dopamine
l'hormone de la récompense quand vous
mangez à un carreau de chocolat ou que
vous vous enfilez un burger sauf que ça
coûte moins de calories et mon argent
la deuxième c'est l'ocytocine l'hormone
de la reconnaissance tout simplement que
vous allez mettre en avant et de
l'empathie
et pour terminer vous avez la sérotonine
ces trois hormones là vous rapprochent
un petit peu plus du bonheur
la dernière chose que j'aimerais mettre
en avant et non des mois c'est le
système d'activation réticulaire
le système d'activation réticulaire est
un ensemble de fibres neuronales situées
dans le tronc cérébral
il s'avère que nous les êtres humains
chaque jour nous avons entre 70 à 80 000
pensées qui traversent notre cerveau et
le système d'activation réticulaire va
venir filtrer ces informations
donc ça va passer de votre inconscient à
votre conscient et une fine vous aurez
que que 6 à 8000 pensées qui viendront
traverser votre cerveau
le système d'activation réticulaire est
en fait basé sur trois choses
préprogrammé ça veut dire qu'elle
diffère d'un individu à un autre vos
croyances vos intérêts
et votre vécu
laissez-moi vous donner un exemple pour
que vous en compreniez les mécanismes
vous avez décidé d'acheter une voiture
flambant neuf 350 chevaux 5 cylindres
les métallisé je peux pas donner la
marque mais c'est ce que je veux
et très bizarrement tout le monde se met
à parler de cette voiture
vous la voyez partout sur la route sur
l'autoroute alors qu'elle coûte très
cher
la soeur du petit copain de la voisine
de votre mère l'a acheté et tout le
monde en parle à la machine à café
étrange coïncidence
non non système d'activation réticulaire
il s'avère que votre système
d'activation articulaire a décidé que
cette information était importante et
que toutes ces voitures que vous
n'auriez pas vu en temps normal toutes
ces discussions que vous n'auriez pas
entendu arrivent jusqu'à votre
conscience
et c'est là que ça devient intéressant
parce qu'en fait ça voudrait dire
que si on élargit ces centres d'intérêt
je mets à m'intéresser à la moto et bien
j'ai beaucoup plus d'informations sur la
moto qui vont arriver à mon cerveau
toutes les choses que je n'aurais pas vu
en temps normal des émissions radio que
je n'aurais pas écouté qui n'auraient
pas alerté des personnes qui auraient
échangé là-dessus un article dans un
journal que je n'aurais même pas
effleurer
idem avec vos croyances
si vous avez des croyances depuis tout
petit qui sont ancrées
et qui vous empêchent de voir certaines
choses ou alors qu'ils vous font voir
trop de choses trop d'informations
peut-être qu'en grandissant vous avez
modifié ces croyances et en modifiant
ces croyances vous allez avoir de
nouvelles informations qui arrivent à
votre cerveau
peut-être pour en remplacer d'autres
donc je vous laisse retenir ces trois
choses qui sont excessivement simples
applicables au quotidien
la lumière la gratitude et le système
d'activation réticulaire
moi c'est ce que j'essaye de mettre en
place pour essayer de faire que mes
journées soient salutaires un maximum
j'aimerais terminer par une histoire que
j'aime beaucoup
et cette histoire est spatiable très
très longtemps au confond de
l'Extrême-Orient ce sont deux moines qui
ont une marche pour aller rejoindre leur
monastère à 20 km en contrebas et pour
se faire ils doivent plonger une rivière
cette marche n'a rien d'anaudre beaucoup
de moines avant que l'on effectués et
elle est faite pour un but précis
compter ses pas prendre conscience
de l'environnement et de la raison pour
laquelle ils effectuent cette marche
soudain de l'autre côté de la rivière
une jeune femme seule et fraise n'arrive
pas à traverser la rivière elle est
glacée par la peur de l'eau sans aucune
hésitation le plus vieux des deux moines
traverse la rivière arrive à sa hauteur
la récupération d'eau
[Musique]
retraverse la rivière et la dépose de
l'autre côté de la rive
les deux moines reprennent leur chemin
quant au bout d'une heure le jeune moine
s'adresse au plus ancien
vénérable vous avez brisé un précepte
vous n'avez pas le droit de toucher une
femme et encore moins de la porter sur
votre dos
l'autre moi ne reste silencieux il
reprend sa marche
et 5 minutes plus tard
il regarde son compère
et prend la parole
mon jeune ami
j'ai déposé la jeune femme de l'autre
côté de Yaris il y a déjà une heure
c'est toi qui la porte encore sur ton
dos
combien d'entre nous sont conditionnés
aujourd'hui
par ce qui leur est arrivé hier
avant-hier
ce matin
où il y a à peine une heure
à mon sens pour que vos journées ne
soient pas des journées catastrophes
enchaînés il faudrait agir ainsi
se dire que la minute qui était coulée
est une minute estompée et que la minute
à venir et celle du champ des possibles
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]